[Music]  the long weekends coming up and I hope  you'll join us here at KY Boyd's Truslow  Park for the annual district Waitangi  Day celebrations this whole area will be  jam-packed full of stalls and there will  be something to see doing eat for every  member of the family with free  entertainment all day long pony rides  Devon should teas and a period costume  competition are just some of the  highlights this year and if your brain  needs the workout put on your sleuthing  cap and search the town center for clues  in our Waitangi Day quiz all that and  more for the Waitangi Day celebrations  here at Kai boys Truslow Park between 10  and 2 o'clock  [Music]